okay everybody I think we'll make a
start if that's okay we make the time
seven o'clock we're just commenting on
the clock up there which is keeping its
own time but we don't think it's right
we gotta get somebody with a ladder in
order to change the time
um welcome to the first cabinet meeting
of uh the new Council
um very pleasant evening
um I'd like to say thank you to the
deputy leader for giving up her evening
on her birthday to come to Cabinet she
knows how to celebrate in style
obviously
um possibly the largest team of officers
I've ever seen at the cabinet meeting I
don't know about anything about you
um and uh it could be and um obviously
welcome to all members who've come along
as well
um firearm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the officers
via the stairs please do not use the
lifts assembly in holy Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls while the meeting is in progress
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
um does anyone intend to film the
meeting
not seeing anybody
um the following members I've asked
already to speak on the council
procedure 20.1 item five councilor
Donaldson item seven uh cancer Jill
bayford item eight Council Jill bayford
item nine councilor Rogers
and item 13 councilor bayford is there
any other members who would like to
speak under 20.1 councilor Pugh
others
six nine and ten please
foreign
thank you
so we've got a nice long agenda this
evening partly as a result of the fact
obviously there can't be any cabinet
meetings over the election period
um without any further ado
[Applause]
uh there can be no apologies because
cabinet is all here
um does anyone have an interest to
declare in the items to business on the
agenda this evening
no Declarations of Interest so we move
on to the minutes of the previous
meeting
on the 16th of March 2023 a copy of
which is attached to the agenda I
propose to take the minutes as red do I
have a secondar
okay councilor Yates
members agree they're cute they've got
the extraordinary meeting which took
place on the 21st of March again the
copy is attached to the agenda pack I
propose we take the minutes as red diver
secondary
councilor Yates thank you members agree
thank you
so we move on to the first substantive
item which is the westgar Westgate on
sea draft neighborhood plan
which is for me to introduce
so the recommendation here is that the
council issues a decision statement that
he accepts a recommendation in the
examiner's report and the draft
neighborhood plan can proceed to
referendum
under the localism ACT 2011 neighborhood
plans could be prepared by local
communities and are led by town or
Parish councils or a neighborhood Forum
in areas which do not have a town or
Parish Council
if thanic Council adopts a noble plan it
would have the same significance as
other development plan documents for
example the local plan for the district
Westgate on C-Town Council has produced
a draft neighborhood plan it's published
and formally submitted to the council
and has subsequently been assessed by an
independent examiner the examiner's
report has also been published it
supports the proposed neighborhood plan
with some minor modifications and
recommends that it'd be subjects or
referendum
the council now has to issue a decision
statement as to whether or not he
accepts the recommendations in the
examiner's report and if not what
actions will be necessary the council
also has to consider whether the draft
plan meets the basic conditions for a
neighborhood plan
the report before cabinet sets out
relevant issues in the examiner's report
for cabinet's decision which will also
form the basis of the decision statement
the trough neighborhood plan is
generally supported it's been positively
prepared and includes policies that
generally conform with the adopted local
plan
it's encouraging to see that the Town
Council has included policies which are
though too detailed or too specific for
the local plan do generally support the
delivery of the local plan and have a
good evidence base for example the
neighborhood plan identifies importancy
front characteristics and designated
seafront character zones to protect
those characteristics
I therefore propose the recommendations
as set out in the report that is that
the West Coast neighborhood player be
modified with the modifications to add
in the examiner's report at Annex one
and that the council issue a decision
statement that the plan should proceed
to referendum is there a second please
secondly by councilor Alban thank you
and I have councilor David Donaldson to
speak
hi good evening I'm David Donaldson
Westgate Ward councilor for TDC and also
the chair of Westgate Town Council
Westgate time Council was formed in 2015
and shortly after its formation it's set
up a working group to produce the
neighborhood plan the working group
went through a long process of
consultation and engagement with the
residents
um this was in fact interrupted by covid
as was everything else and now we
finally reached um the final stage which
is uh where you know we we've it's been
been put to the examiners the examiners
seem to be um uh happy with the plan so
we've maybe passed our examination but
this has been a gigantic task
um and I'm not sure which exam we passed
but I think the somebody who goes
through this process you know kind of
deserves a PhD or something
um Jill gray who uh has been leading on
this our town councilor Our Town Clark
you know has done an absolutely
fantastic and Splendid job and also
Daniel Dunn who's from Goldstone town
planning and supported this so I would
like to ask the Covenant to support
um this motion this evening and that you
know we can then progress to a
referendum thank you
thank you councilor Donaldson um has any
members like to comment on the Escape
telephone labor plan
okay so cabinets asked that the
neighborhood plan be modified us out in
the report and the council issues the
decision statement that he accepts the
recommendations and examiners report and
the draft neighborhood plan can proceed
to referendum do members agree great
great thank you
we move on to item six which is the
amendment to the air quality management
Zone and it's councilor King
welcome to Cabinet Council again thank
you
okay so sanit District Council is
committed to improving the environment
for all our residents and reducing
Health inequalities often associated
with air pollution
air quality is improved across than it
in the last five years there have been
no exceedances of national air quality
objectives across the district during
this period government guidance and
defra Appraisal of the local Authority's
annual air quality status reports
recommend that TDC considers revocation
of the air quality management area
advising that no aqma should remain
where there have been five years of
compliance with the air quality
objectives
a detailed assessment of two former
pollution hotspots was undertaken using
traffic data and dispersion modeling to
predict levels across the entire area
the report indicates a risk of exceeding
guideline levels at a number of
properties between High streets in
Lawrence and Shire Place Ramsgate the
local Authority has increased monitoring
within this area to determine whether
real world measurements do reflect the
modeled exceedances
the Declaration of the smaller more
defined aqma will give a pro appropriate
weight and focus for improvement
measures within the subsequent action
plan
I therefore ask the cabinet approved the
report recommendations to revoke the
existing Urban eqma order and approve
the Declaration to the smaller St
Lawrence one and authorize the
application of the common seal to the
order
thank you chair I simply wanted to ask a
question I welcome the focus on this
area which is primarily in my ward
because it is a an area where there is a
great deal of traffic and a lot of uh a
lot of potential pollution I'm just
wondering whether what flexibility we
have to look at other areas if as
development
continues in some of our rural areas Etc
are there other areas we can focus on or
is this it now for the next five years I
I don't quite understand the process I
wonder if you could explain or if the
officer could explain
um thank you Council Austin I think it's
in a number of our Awards actually
because I think that this area is around
a junction of about four different Wards
in Ramsgate yeah yeah
um
okay please
um we monitor uh pollution levels across
the district
um and it's this small area that is
showing potential of coming close to
exceeding the objectives the modeling
has said it's at risk and so we've
deployed a lot more monitoring diffusion
tubes in that area so we can see if it
actually does represent real-world
conditions and but we do monitor across
than it and if there's any
um if you're concerned about a
particular area we can always look to
put monitoring in that around those
areas just to check those um levels
thank you
okay thank you and I have to say from
from you know basic observation I'm not
surprised that that's a place where we
would want to do air quality monitoring
because it does seem to me there's a bit
of a traffic issue there and queuing
traffic around the Junctions
um right so that's been moved executive
members have any further comment on that
not seeing anything so are members happy
to agree to approve the revocation of
the urban aqma order and approve the
Declaration of the smaller Defiance to
Lawrence aqma and authorize the
application of the common seal to the
order
members agree thank you
and we can move on to item seven which
is the building safety act 2022 and
councilor Whitehead
thank you very much leader
this evening cabinets with us to firstly
approve the recommendation to name
thanet District Council as the
accountable person as described in the
building safety act 2022 secondly
approve the recommendation to name the
director of place as the principal
accountable person again as described in
the building safety act 2022
thirdly approve the adoption of the
revised fire risk assessment policy and
finally delegate authority to the
director of place to approve future
minor amendments required to the fire
risk assessment policy
the Safety and Security of our residents
is Paramount and external legislation
that supports this and strengthens our
ability to protect residents is welcomed
today we are discussing the building
safety act brought in in 2022
this is new legislation designed to
enhance the safety of high-rise
residential buildings
something that is of an enormous
importance and significance both in
relation to the timing of this report
coming as it does one day after the
anniversary of the terrible events at
grenfell and in relation to the greater
protections that we can bring to our
high-rise stock
the building safety act introduces new
duties relating to Fire and Building
Safety and covers all high-rise
buildings
it is important to note that this
legislation applies to all high-rise
buildings not just those in social
housing stock and tenants in privately
owned high-rises can and should seek
assurances from their landlord or
leaseholder that this legislation is
being followed and can contact our
private sector housing team if they have
concerns
what we are looking at today in terms of
cabinet decision is how we are enacting
the support and protections required and
how it applies specifically to us as a
social landlord
the plan set out here today relate to
the council's tenant and leasehold
service and the council's management of
its social housing stock
we own six high-rise residential
buildings over 18 meters that fall into
the scope of this new legislation
the ACT introduces the requirement for
each of these buildings to have their
own Building Safety case
the building safety case should
demonstrate the following
the measures being taken to keep the
building safe how the measures in place
prevent and limit the consequences of a
major incident in the building
identify potentially harmful events that
show the measures in place will stop or
reduce the impact of a major incident
I.E fire spread or structural failure
and the approach to ongoing management
of the building that ensures those
measures remain effective
the purpose of a building safety case is
to collate and record all information
about how the risk of fire spread and
the structural safety of the building is
managed
this is something that we already do for
each of our high rises but the ACT
requires a particular format and this
information now has to be submitted
annually to a new regulator for building
safety which provides further external
structure to the internal processes that
we have been following for some time to
guarantee resident safety
the new regulator for building safety is
the health and safety executive
They will receive our annual reports to
ensure that guidance is being followed
the ACT introduces two new roles and
responsibilities for landlords or
building owners
the two new roles that created are those
of the accountable person and principal
accountable person
this report makes a recommendation on
who these should be within the existing
structure recommending that the council
itself be registered as the accountable
person with our director of place Mr Bob
Porter being the principal accountable
person
some changes are required within the
team to accommodate the new requirements
these changes are recorded within the
report but principal changes are as
follows
a new post of building safety and
compliance manager has been introduced
this allows the focus required to ensure
we are fully complying with the new
requirements
the council's fire risk assessment
policy has been reviewed in line with
the building safety act and changes to
the regulatory reform order
2005. in relation to fire safety
we will also be making enhancements to
our current compliance database to hold
all new information required by the ACT
the ACT also strengthens existing Fire
Safety Orders including for buildings
over 11 meters in height
there are 17 of these within our housing
stock
reflecting our priorities established
when we brought housing back in-house
the ACT requires a significant level of
focus on Resident involvement and
engagement to ensure that residents feel
safe secure and hard
thanks to our ongoing focus on Resident
involvement our resident involvement
strategy
2022-2025 addresses the requirements of
the building safety act 2022 but further
engagement and strengthening of that
involvement is desirable
we will be creating a new high-rise
tenant and leaseholder group to ensure
that the voices of those living within
our high-rise buildings are heard and
will continue to consult regularly with
our existing tenant and leaseholder
group so that opportunities to feed into
these processes are visible flexible and
promote a quality of access
the measures cabinet are bringing
forward today are of utmost importance
and I have every faith in housing to
deliver what is required to support our
tenants
I move the report
thank you councilor Whitehead do you
have a second
councilor Yates thank you councilor
Beaufort
thank you chair thank you councilor
Whitehead for the report
um I welcome this report as ensuring the
safety of our resident is vital I
support the proposal to appoint DDC as
the accountable person and director of
place as the principal accountable
person
contribution of our tenants and
leaseholders through the tenant and
leaseholders service has proved to be
invaluable in highlighting issues of
concern I am Keen that this consultation
continues with the new building safety
act and I'm pleased to hear that you
have this in place thank you
thank you very much councilor bayford
new councilor Beaufort
um obviously this is a very important
subject it's quite a dry
document and an action that's requested
to the council but it is of absolute
importance in terms of the safety of our
residents
members have anything to say further on
this no okay our members I'll read the
recommendations again approve the
recommendation to the infantic district
councils the accountable person is
describing the building safety act 2022
approved the recommendation to name the
director of places the principal
accountable person as described in the
building safety act 2022 approved the
adoption of the revised fire risk
assessment policy and delegate authority
of the director of place to it says on
my script leaves it hanging
to make minor remembers
great start yeah
um do members agree
okay thank you and before we uh before
we move on completely to item eight
we'll move on to artemite I have spotted
a tire powering item mate which I'm
going to point out before that becomes
another trap one of the recommendations
says to recommend a full Council that
1.119 million have grown and
1996 million HRA match funding I think I
think that requires a decimal point
which I'm sure councilor Whitehead would
have pointed out when she introduced the
report which she's going to do now thank
you
Steve
[Laughter]
so this evening cabinet is being asked
to firstly recommend to the full Council
that the 1.19 million of Grant at 1.96
million HRA match funding is included in
the HRA Capital program and secondly
agree to receive a further report to
approve the expenditure and the
acquisition of nine homes
in bringing this proposal to Cabinet I
want to be as clear but as detailed as
possible
this is the first meeting for this
proposal to be discussed
there will be plenty of time further
discussion later but I feel it's very
important to explain exactly what is
being proposed now as I am aware of a
level of confusion relating to this
proposal and it is important to have
both a financial and a moral context
the resettlement of refugees from both
Ukraine and Afghanistan has in many ways
lacked the central Focus that good
support required
fulfunding needing to have been given to
councils with statutory housing
obligations to provide for refugees in a
way that could provide reliable housing
and support those who have experienced
war and disruption often especially in
the case of the resettlement schemes
linked to Afghanistan those who've
provided support to British forces and
need our support now
this lack of a foundational approach has
proved difficult for many councils to
manage as it has resulted in complex
homelessness cases and the use of
accommodation that I would consider to
be unsuitable to provide for individuals
and families whilst they are under the
care of the home office
the government recently announced
details of a national 500 million pound
scheme which goes some way towards
remedying this situation
the local Authority housing support fund
has been created to enable local
authorities to purchase properties in
their area to accommodate both Ukrainian
and Afghan Refugee households
for an issue and initial period of three
years
this funding allocation was offered to
182 local authorities in England by
means of match funding
fun it was one of these local
authorities and central government is
funding 35 to 40 of the cost of
providing nine properties for this
purpose
a memorandum of understanding was
returned to the department for leveling
up housing communities otherwise known
as Deluxe excitingly in March 2023 which
registered the council's interest in the
scheme
in order to utilize the grant it will be
necessary to match fund the Acquisitions
with 1.96 million of additional
borrowing within the HRA Capital program
the properties must be purchased by 30th
of November 2023.
any properties acquired will form part
of the council's housing stock with the
income and expenditure managed within
the housing revenue account
the homes can subsequently be used to
accommodate households from the
council's housing waiting list
providing a new and permanent supply of
accommodation will also help to address
local housing and homelessness pressures
as a council and as a community we have
a moral duty to do our best to house
those who are most vulnerable
and we do well in discharging that Duty
and we'll continue to do so
we have
3470 properties within our housing
portfolio all General needs housing all
used by residents who have been on our
housing list
what is proposed here relating to the
very specific requirements of a
particular governmental fund is the
purchase of nine homes all of which will
eventually become General needs housing
for the current usage of refugees from
both the Ukraine and Afghanistan who
have arrived here as part of the
following government-led schemes
the Afghan citizen resettlement scheme
including eligible British Nationals
under this scheme the Afghan relocations
and assistance policy the Ukraine family
scheme homes for Ukraine and the UK next
Ukraine extension scheme
there are particular requirements for
the homes to be acquired and a very
short time scale to acquire them in
at least two of the homes purchased are
required to have four bedrooms the
remaining homes are required to be two
or three bedroom homes
discussions have taken place with a
local housing developer to potentially
purchase six three bed units and three
four bed units to meet the above
requirements
the units will be newly constructed with
no refurbishments or adaptations needed
they are nearing completion and will be
ready by the end of June 2023 which
allows us to meet the requirements of
the funding and the short time scale of
November 2023
this mix of units meets the requirements
of the grant as at least two or four
bedroom homes
there are to my mind two main issues to
consider in relation to this item and
both are interlinked
firstly as human beings under the
council we have a moral duty to do our
best to support those in need and those
who are vulnerable
this grant partial though it is supports
us to fulfill that moral duty and
provide specifically for individuals who
are protected with an oral qualities act
commitments
secondly the fund also supports the
growth of our housing portfolio in
general which allows us to support all
residents in the long term
I especially am keenly aware of the
issues surrounding rate and rent
inflation in Bennett and the need for
social housing as evidenced over many
years of council debates
and our ongoing and future build and
acquisition plans reflect this General
need
the addition of a further 42 new homes
to our housing portfolio and our forward
plan yesterday indicates our initial
inroads into our ambitious social and
affordable rent program
however provision for one in this case
is provision for all and is a
significant contribution to our housing
infrastructure and it is important to
consider the full scope of both the fund
and our contribution to it in both a
moral and a financial sense
and move the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you councilor Whitehead is there a
second
secondly by councilor Yates I'll bring
you counselor Beaufort
thank you chair thank you councilor
Whitehead
it is of course sensible that we take
advantage of the government allocated
1.9 million towards purchases purchasing
nine new homes but tdc's HRA
contribution of 1.96 million is a sum
that would enable us to build five to
six properties without the support
I would ask therefore how the council
will address issues where the Afghan or
Ukrainian tenants are not ready to move
on after the initial period of three
years
thank you very much for your question
councilor bayford there have been a lot
of questions
um from housing going to central
government to ask for the specifics in
relation to this fund because
it wasn't especially clear to be honest
um so the match funding that we have as
you noted is 35 to 40 percent which
requires us if we want to use it to
supplement it from our HRA
so
it's significant to my mind that those
properties do come back into the
portfolio overall
however there is nothing to my knowledge
that specifies exactly what is to happen
at the end of that point
it's important to know the scale of our
housing portfolio overall however in
these are nine properties from what will
hopefully be several thousand Properties
by the end of that three-year period so
we may be providing for a particular
purpose at this point but those are
properties that will eventually come
back into our portfolio but I'm happy to
pass over to Mr Porter if we've had any
further guidance from central government
thank you
thank you there isn't any specific
guidance that we've seen that says
exactly how that
mechanism will work the guidance
attached to the funding says that they
should be used for the purpose of
Ukrainian and Afghan refugees for as
long as they're required for that
purpose and then they would return to
General needs housing stock for letting
to people on the register
um I think the key thing about um
the costs I think it's probably worth
highlighting is that in all of our
building programs we're building for
affordable rent and the council has an
adopted policy for affordable rent and
the subsidy levels that we use to
support those programs whether they're
from Grant from homes England or in this
case Grant from d-luck or it could be
our the use of our rights by one for one
receipts all of those programs subsidize
the the cost by about around about 40
percent
um and at 40 subsidy
um generally we can build for affordable
rent
um lettings and make that those schemes
that cover their costs over the period
of the of the business plan and actually
add value to the business plan so in in
the long term the more homes that we
build at that kind of subsidy rate and
at that rent level the more we can build
um so you know it's adding every every
home adds value to the plan
[Music]
I think from my point of view
um
the council can't be in the position of
turning down a grant of what over a
million pounds towards social housing
and I think morally the council can't be
in a position of of Turning Away
um this offer because that it's directed
at refugees particularly from
Afghanistan a new crime it is
unfortunate that it's come forward at
the beginning of the new Administration
in relative isolation because we would
like to have seen it been able to do it
as part of an overall plan to increase
our social housing stock that's
certainly Our intention and I understand
um people in the community saying well
what about us I think it's up for the
count up to the council to answer that
question and certainly this
Administration intends to do exactly
that but this project stands alone it
has to be dealt with now clearly there
was a
uh contact with government before the
election by the previous administration
an indication that they wish to support
this scheme
um and I think it's right that we go
forward with it but it's up to the
council to one make a success of this
but also to demonstrate that it's going
to provide more affordable housing for
residents Who currently live in the area
members anybody who wish to say anything
I'll give you more opportunity for
future counselor album
okay do members agree
okay thank you and it's 1.996 million I
believe
um right item nine is the vehicle
replacement program and that is cancer
Alvin
here I am okay
um
this report seeks cabinet approval to
start spending from the agreed
2.115 million of allocated budget for
23.24 on the purchase of four 12-ton
replacement refuse vehicles that have
reached the end of their useful life
these purchases have been considered in
line with the council's agreed Net Zero
strategy and although where possible and
based on advances in technology we have
allowed for electric vehicles and the
additional Associated cost of these
due to constraints around current
infrastructure vehicle range and
requirements it will not be possible to
purchase these particular vehicles as
diesel alternatives
as indicated the vehicle replacement
program for this financial year does
assume where possible that electric
vehicles will be acquired this will mean
purchasing
tried and tested vehicles that have
proved to be fit for purpose
in this particular phase this will
predominantly be car derived Vans and
other smaller Vehicles up to seven and a
half tons
a further more detailed report on this
will be brought back to Cabinet in due
course and to support this work is
underway to establish the full extent of
the infrastructure investment required
to support the electrification of our
Fleet moving forwards
in accordance with Section
13.03 B of the Constitution this report
seeks approval of a key decision to
spend against disagreed budget
allocation for the purchase of
replacement vehicles
and I moved a recommendation in up in
option one of the report thank you
thank you Council I was just a second
for that councilor Yates
and I have uh councilor
thank you leader thank you councilor
Auburn at this time I don't have a
problem with purchasing diesel vehicles
but with regard to paragraph 2.3 I'm
concerned that you state that electric
versions will be purchased within the
2324 replacement program because there's
an ongoing debate as to how eco-friendly
they really are Volvo have released
figures stating that gas emissions are
70 higher manufacturing electric car
rather than a petrol car a huge amount
of energy is required to make the
lithium-ion battery and they are
extremely heavy and in perfect device
for an electric car and concerns have
been raised about them being used in
trucks because of their weight and about
the context of the batteries which are
toxic and can contaminate the
environment at the end of their life
would it be safer to wait a while before
as there are better Alternatives being
developed thank you
thank you councilor Rogers um I don't
know whether anyone wishes to comment on
that do you want to sign yeah yeah
um thank you Council Rogers I think it's
uh made it plain within the in in the
report that the electric vehicles that
we look at it they've got to be fit for
purpose and I think that's that's the
whole point otherwise we would have gone
stuck in straight in with the electric
vehicles
um certainly in relation to the the 12
ton vehicles
um
it's only recently I think about a month
ago that one company uh has now just
started up with 12-ton electric vehicles
which are actually waste Vehicles
because the majority well and otherwise
all the 12 Town vehicles are there are
of Van like for carrying goods Etc
um and not waste trucks so uh and
obviously the waste trucks the the power
to lift whatever they've got to lift and
also to crush what they've got what
they've got to crash so the important
part of that is for us to look to see
that they are what we require and how we
need it and that will and that will go
forward thank you
thank you well I think the direction of
travels fairly fairly clear if you'll
forgive the
yeah uh
Council Austin
thank you chair thank you councilor
Alvin
um I was going to ask us as opposed a
parallel question which is in view of
the way that the technology is changing
so fast in view of the fact that new
vehicles are being introduced all the
time and that I understand with regard
to the waste Vehicles the main problem
at the moment with moving to Electric is
to do with range
um have we considered the possibility
maybe of leasing diesel vehicles as a
temporary measure while we see how how
the market develops
yeah I'll come back on that chair yeah I
the issue
is as I just said there is just one
company started
producing 12-ton vehicles
a month ago
so we don't know we don't know the
viability of them we don't know how
they're going to work we don't know
there's lots of don't knows about this
particular vehicle so
um that's something we need to look at
and and as well as that we've got to
sort out our charging
abilities at Madison Road Depot and also
as well what we don't want to get is
caught out halfway around around and the
vehicles pack up because there's they're
running out of charge because the amount
of energy that they've got to use up so
um I think
the way that this needs to be we do need
to purchase these vehicles rather than
rent rent the vehicles or hire them
um so that is the
proposal chair
Council Yates yeah it's just to just to
add the
um the climate change government advisor
group
um is likely likely to be discussing the
vehicle replacement scheme in addition
to the operational Services it might not
be the first meeting over the second
meeting of the climate change CAG
um so that we can provide that
information about what are the time
scales for the electric vehicle charging
points at our Depots so I think Mike
wants to chip in on that things
yeah thank you thank you thank you
leader I just wanted to add add on the
um issue of lease versus purchase where
we we haven't looked at it specifically
in this instance with your question
about electric vehicles but where we've
looked at leasing before it's roughly
twice the cost of purchase over the
whole life of the vehicle I think if we
look and we know that purchasing an
electric vehicle currently they are
roughly twice the capital cost of you
know for electric vehicle versus a Euro
six diesel engine vehicle so I think
leasing an electric vehicle you know
would be quite a lot more for the whole
life of the vehicle than than purchase
oh sorry so I think yeah that that same
uh sort of principle applies it's
roughly twice the cost of capital
purchase yeah
[Music]
okay thank you for that um I think again
um it's unfortunate that one of the
first acts of the of the new
um Administration is to uh buy more
diesel vehicles because that isn't where
any of us want to be and I think we may
have disagreements about which
technology we need to use going forward
but certainly we would have preferred
not to be in this place obviously this
was another decision which couldn't be
made before the election I obviously
wasn't available at the time
um to members agree
thank you should we move on to item 10
which is the UK shared Prosperity fund
update from councilor Duckworth
as outlined within the reports and it
was allocated just over 1.1 million
pounds until March 2026 to deliver the
proposals within the UK shared
Prosperity fund
the report requests cabinet to note the
inclusion of the capital element into
our Capital program and to authorize
commencement of delivery
we understand that this funding program
is meant to be replacing European funds
which then it previously benefited from
and the funding allocation was a viral
formula
however I am sure you will agree that
it's likely that further funding will be
required to ensure we are able to make a
difference to our local communities
the report sets out the priorities for
the funding and links directly back to
the guidance set out by central
government as mentioned in the report
the budgets will be reprofiled some of
this will be informed by the mapping
work that's being commissioned
I urge all councilors to attend the
members briefing next Tuesday which will
be online
where officers will present further
information about the program and what
the next steps will be we will also
require your help to inform the
voluntary community and social
Enterprise mapping tell us who is in
your ward and share the information that
we send out
this is a technical recommendation
requesting the ability to deliver the
program
I propose the cabinet note the capital
program will need to be amended to
include Capital element of the UK shares
Prosperity fund
approve the commencement of procurement
activities that exceed 250 000 pounds in
order to deliver the UK shared
Prosperity program as outlined in
section 2 than its UK shared Prosperity
fund program
three the head of regeneration and
growth is authorized to agree
appropriate contracts and spend in
collaboration with the cabinet member
for regeneration and property in order
to deliver the projects within the
council's processes and procedures thank
you
thank you Council that was there a
second after that Council Yates
and uh Council appeal before I introduce
you I mean let me um congratulate you on
your elevation to leadership of the of
the conservative group I obviously
obviously wanted to do that at annual
Council but you were unavoidably unable
to join us so we're pleased to see you
here tonight and look forward to hearing
what you've got to say thank you
thank you chair you know I'm not stuck
on the M11 with a broken down car
counselor our account came and picked me
up tonight to avoid that problem
um but no thank you thank you chair
um a Thursday to wish councilor
Whitehead happy birthday really
um I can think of better places to spend
all of our birthdays
um but it doesn't mean that councilor
Whitehead wants to be any less than we
do
um pleasure
um I'd first like to say that you know I
take no credit as the former Cabinet
member uh when this initial bid was put
in some years ago
um I'm very much welcome this
um it's absolutely fantastic that we've
secured this funding
um but it's through no one else's hard
work apart from offices and the head of
regeneration
um particularly with you know how
extensive these bids need to be
um I think as as means has been has been
outlined within the report and what as
was within the initial bid I think it's
really important that we support people
to to gain new skills and new employment
opportunities particularly linking in
with creative Center sector in Margate
in The Wider area and of course the
Marine with everything that's happening
with leveling up uh down at the Port of
ramsca as well so I really think that
this is really encouraging and it's
certainly a good start but more fund is
needed
um the only real question I have is that
considering that the time scales are
going to be shortened by a year and I
appreciate that's not our making but
because of the time it's taken to be
awarded this I suppose I'm I'm Keen to
understand what the risk is that we
don't deliver all of this scheme in the
time that's been allocated and
particularly I wouldn't want us to have
to kind of hand any of that money back
to central government I think it's
important that we either seek an
extension I suppose that's what I'm
asking would we be able to seek an
extension or is it that um we'll just go
a little bit nuts to ensure there's no
money left by the end to the um the
deadline thank you
thank you I don't know if I canceled
that you wish to comment or would you
like to hand over to the head of
regeneration I would like to hand over
to the headers
uh thank you yes um it was actually six
months worth of funding because the
initial year was six months the year one
was six months so it's only six months
it's been rolled into year two and one
of the other things that we did was
argue for more funding
um to provide the administer
administrative support within the local
Authority so there was a cap of four
percent and we argued for ten and to
include hiring an officer within the
team rather than Outsourcing that work
and so we have a dedicated officer who
will be delivering the program which
means we are therefore able to kind of
dedicate some proper time and resource
to delivering the activity
um by next week we'll have a commission
out to complete the mapping exercise
which will then help inform things like
the grant program and we're working with
other community organizations already to
develop up some of those things that we
can hit the ground running and we
definitely anticipate spending the money
within the required time and hopefully
asking for some more
thanks for that members have any other
comments okay I've got a call in Council
Austin sorry nearly forgot your
counselors
Unthinkable sure
um thank you um I actually had three
questions and uh councilor Duckwood has
already answered one which was about how
Ward councilors can help and where we'll
get more detail about this which
hopefully will be in the briefing it's
great to hear that our help will be
welcomed on this because we're very keen
to to get involved in it the second
question uh councilor Pugh has asked
which was about risk and uh getting
everything done in the time scale my
third question is about the skills
element
um as many of you know I'm a skills
person and I'm very keen to see this
prioritized I'm a bit concerned that
some of the skill stuff seems to be
happening rather late particularly the
green skills bit and I'm wondering if is
that because we're not expecting that
the leveling up work will be in a place
where we can use it until then or are
there other reasons involved in that
thank you that sounds like a question
for me to ask you to me
thanks
um the skills element is at the back of
the program because that was how it was
set out by central government so they'd
um set out over the three-year period
when Parts should be delivered so when
we submitted our investment plan that's
how we profiled it since since we've
been awarded the funding I think that is
changing and government is now
suggesting that you could do skills
elements earlier but obviously we'd
spent a lot of time putting in the kind
of profile on the basis of the
information we had before us so we are
now reviewing how we will deliver that
and I think we're still waiting for some
further guidance
um but
um
the program the ambition of the program
was to be informed at the outset to then
use that information to deliver across
the back end of the the program and it's
also the way the funding is profiled so
in year three there's a bigger amount of
funding than there was a new one in year
two
thank you
thanks for that members any further
comment on that one
okay I certainly welcome the fact that
we're going to get a briefing on it
because I think we were discussing
earlier that the it's quite technical
the report and quite quite opaque so I
think uh some explanation would be
welcome for most members including the
leader
okay so cabinets asked to note the
capital program will need to be amended
to include the capital of the UK's
shared Prosperity fund approve the
commencement of procurement activities
that exceed 250 000 in order to deliver
the UK share Prosperity program as
outlined in section two then it's UK
share Prosperity fund program to agree
that the head of regeneration of growth
is authorized to agree appropriate
contacts and contracts and spending
collaboration with a Cabinet member for
regeneration of property in order to
deliver the projects within the
council's processes and procedures do
members agree thank you we move on to
item 11 which is the procurement of a
CCTV installations repair and
preventative maintenance contract which
is councilor key
thank you
then it District Council is committed to
improving the community safety directly
relating to this commitment is the
council's ability to reduce crime and
the impact of criminality upon the
district and address anti-social
behavior and related flight tipping
complaints
CCTV is Central to delivering this
commitment with 533 CCTV cameras across
towns housing stock and Council owned
sites
the current CCTV contract for
installation and planned and
preventative maintenance which was
awarded under a crown commercial service
framework is due to expire
the council wishes to make use of crown
commercial service framework once again
as the method for procure services for
CCTV in relation to public space
surveillance systems along with housing
CCTV and Council building CCTV the value
of the contract under the duration of
terms is 650 000 pounds
I would like to recommend that cabinet
exercises its powers and approves this
recommendation for use of the crown
commercial service framework as the
method to place a direct award to
British telecoms PLC in relation to CCTV
Services
inclusive of installation and repairs
maintenance for a minimum period for
three years
thank you
thank you councilor kings are a second
after that
thank you members wish to discuss that
one
counselor album
yeah sorry
um it's it's just the question Maria and
I think Mr geddies might be the person
to answer that question
um
as some of us know especially in
Ramsgate we've got uh the police head
gave money for cctvs to be put up in
such place for instance in Albion
Gardens in Ramsgate the actual uh the
actual Mast that it's going to be
sitting on has been there for nearly a
year and CCTV hasn't been in hasn't been
installed so I just wondering uh when
they are finally installed will that
come through will that CCTV come through
to our operation
um thank you for your question counselor
Alban
um I work going to all the gaudy details
of the tales of War of the Ramsgate CCTV
camera installation what I can do is
give confirmation that three of the
camera systems will be operational
within the next two weeks the remaining
two will be fully operational within the
next two months or will terminate at the
control room and all will have the
ability to be monitored all day every
day and we'll record 24 7.
thank you just what I wanted to hear
thank you
yes I can think of another eastcliff
counselor it'll be very uh interested in
that response
okay members it's been moved and
seconded um I'll read the recommendation
again that the use of the crown
commercial service framework Lot 12 be
agreed as the method to place a direct
towards British telecommunications PLC
in relation to CCTV services around
public space surveillance systems
housing stocks CCTV and corporate assets
CCTV inclusive installation repairs
maintenance for a minimum period of
three years that's been moved and
secondly to members agree thank you
we move on to item 12 which is Corporate
performance quarter 4 20 22 23 which is
May
so the report in front of members sets
out
as part of the council's corporate
performance process 39 key performance
indicators which are monitored to
provide an indication of how the council
is performing they don't look at every
aspect of the council services and the
date of the council clicks but they do
provide an overview of progress against
the council's key corporate priorities
other data was collected and monitored
at a service level Performance
Management is a key part of the
corporate governance process and adds
value by hoping to ensure accountability
of the performance of the council
services against the corporate
objectives this helps to encourage
enhanced accountability and continuous
Improvement the data for most of the
corporate indicators is now available to
view on our website at any time
uh it's been a great previously that a
six-monthy report of the council's
corporate performance will be shared
with the overview and scrutiny panel and
the cabinet to provide an opportunity to
move to more closely review the
direction of travel on our key service
areas this will allow sufficient time
for actions and issues to be resolved
between committee meetings and as the
data for the corporate performance
indicators is on the website the report
presented this evening identifies the
data as at the end of quarter four which
is up to the end of March the data
captured is when the format was changed
to provide the public the clear and easy
access to information on hacking
Services performing detailed graphs are
also included to give a wider view of
the direction of travel for each
indicator this report has previously
been to overview and scrutiny panel on
the 30th of May so we thank them for
their engagement and feedback
and I move the cabinet note the report
so a second for that
as seconded by councilor Alvin uh
members have any comments
okay
thanks very much we will move on to item
13.
which is the tenant and leaseholder
services kpi quarter three and quarter
four housing performance report so very
much the same thing from a housing
perspective which once again is Council
Whitehead
thank you very much Luther
this evening cabinet is asked to note
and scrutinize the contents of the
reports for quarters three and four
every quarter tenant and leaseholder
services bring forward performance
reports to overview and scrutiny and to
cabinet
this is a requirement of the council's
landlord compliance policies and allows
the opportunity for early intervention
should any performance issues arise
tonight I have the pleasure of
presenting the quarter 3 and quarter 4
report
I'm very pleased to be able to State the
performance for five of the six landlord
health and safety compliance work
streams remain steady a hundred percent
these work streams operate as business
as usual and the team's work to a
complete outstanding actions within set
time frames
compliance for domestic electrical
safety certificates has remained at
around 90 for most of this financial
year
the service has ensured that
certificates are renewed at the end of
their five-year cycle
but has struggled to completely clear
the backlog of certification works
access to properties has been an issue
and a cause of delays in certification
and processes are now in place to ensure
that certifications can be completed
additional resources and stronger
contract management have been deployed
to address the backlog and the petition
is starting to improve during quarter
three and quartus 4.
operational performance has seen some
success and there are areas that are
being actively improved
quarter 3 always reflects the increased
demand we see during the winter months
with the concurrent and usual trend of a
fallen performance for partnering
contractors and their customer
satisfaction due to increased pressures
both contractors recovered in quarter
four with Mia's finishing the year with
90.3 percent customer satisfaction
the contract with gas call the
partnering contractor for gas appliance
repairs and gas compliance program came
to an end on 31st the 3rd 23.
a new contractor was successful in the
recent procurement exercise and BSW
started as our new gas contractor on 1st
of the 4th 23.
the capital budget spend has been
disappointing this year due to key
contractors going into Administration
housing never exists in isolation and
the ongoing challenges of external
Financial pressures are filled across
the service but especially with an honor
external systems
the team are procuring replacement
contracts which are set to be in place
this financial year which will improve
the capital budget spend position
there's been significant success in
improving Voyage turnaround performance
and also in reducing arrears
this is a huge success for the team who
have steadily reduced arrears despite a
very difficult operating environment
areas are two percent lower now than
when the service transitioned from East
Kent housing on October 2020
which indicates outstanding support for
residents and performance from the team
considering significant financial and
cost of living challenges that have
marked the last year
I move the report
thank you councilor Whitehead is there a
second of all
councilor Yates and last up is councilor
bayford
thank you chair thank you councilor
Whitehead
um I'd also like to thank Sally for her
clear and transparent reports as always
I'm placed at the forced entry procedure
has been successfully implemented where
electrical certificates are concerned
and ask whether this is applied to other
services such as fire safety as the
inability to access properties seems to
be delaying progress and incurring costs
in ensuring the safety of our residents
thank you councilor bayford councilor
White thank you councilor bayford
um obviously we already have that in
place in relation to gas and we now have
it in place in relation to Electric
in terms of the specifics of our fire
safety I'm happy to pass over to Mr
Sullivan
thank you
um so for other compliance matters where
health and safety is involved we can use
a forced access process where other
properties and other residents are
affected by the non-compliance of a
single resident so for example in a
block of flats if um
we have a tank which is only accessible
through a water tank accessible through
a one particular residence home but it
affects all the residents in that block
of flats then we can force access there
if
another example is where that was a
house and it only affected that
residence we couldn't Force access
access in that situation and that's true
across all compliance work streams
thank you for that uh members do you
know the contents of the report
that's a great thank you that concludes
the business for tonight's meeting I
declare the meeting closed out I make it
7 57 I'll defer to Charles if he
disagrees
um the live stream of the meeting will
now end thank you very much to all these
officers who've attended give out their
evening this evening and to members
who've joined us as well
and enjoy the rest of the evening thank
you
it's not all going to be 13 items
no it was but